[Applause]
i got a call
the very unusual call that there was an
eagle that was stuck in a tree
at the alaska raptor center we answer
hundreds of phone calls for injured
birds a year
but never have i had one like this
no i don't think it's alive i think it
died
its wing is like
there's some blood on its tail alaska is
a great place for bald eagles
in the lower 48 you might see one or two
bald eagles at a time but here in alaska
you see them everywhere and when they
get into trouble
we're here to help towards the eagle can
you see it moving at all
extend if you have more extension all
right let's try that
it's alive
wow i can't believe he's alive i thought
for sure he was dead
are you gonna go up do you want me to go
up craig dr victoria is the vet at the
raptor center
and she definitely goes above and beyond
i started
working in 1993 so
how many rescues have i done so many i
can't even begin
to count but this rescue today is going
to be like
none i have ever done it definitely went
through it like a good
that much you could see the blood and
feathers all over the
stick so i'm a member of the fire
department
which is probably the only reason
they're gonna let me do this to allow
a bird to just hang from a tree and die
that's not right
if we can do something to help it so i
want her locked in
up on the tip before we go up gotta want
to see it from this angle
okay uh my job will be to just get the
eagle
ideally i'll just be grabbing it by its
legs and i'll
most likely be hanging it upside down
that's the safest thing for me
and the eagle i've done this a lot never
on a big high ladder
it'll be teamwork what's her name
austin okay i'm victoria and then i just
walk
you told me it was gonna feel weird and
it does
now put your knee down on that next
another one
got it all right austin i want you
against her ready yeah i'm good i'm
cooking
all right austin we're gonna be watching
branches
straight ahead i never
ever thought i would be going up on a
ladder
on a fire truck to rescue an eagle just
never crossed my mind
okay stop and i can see it's not going
to be easy
okay austin i'm going to grab the eagle
there's going to be lots of drama and i
might fall off when folks come to alaska
they really want to see those
charismatic megafauna right
all the kind of native alaskan wildlife
that you would think of when you think
of alaska
so you know all of our bears our coyotes
our foxes
our sica deer our moose they all come in
injured or orphaned in some form or
fashion
[Music]
muskogs a lot of visitors actually get
those guys confused with bison
but they are completely separate species
they're actually found above the arctic
circle
today we have a rare chance to add to
our herd we got a call for baby
orphan muskox on the slope that we're
getting ready to go pick up
[Music]
she's coming from the end of the road as
far as driving as far north as you can
possibly go in alaska the very tip of
the state
so it's going to be a long day for her
being in a kennel going through a bunch
of different flights before she finally
gets to anchorage
[Music]
uh so this little baby girl muskox she's
kind of been through a lot the last 24
hours
she's been chased around by a grizzly
start and then she was crowded by
two-legged humans and then she was
captured and put in a kennel
it's kind of like being picked up by
aliens for her
a little stressful for her thank you a
little baby
it's a lot smaller than i thought she
was gonna be oh my god she's so
cute oh she is adorable
she's from my understanding she's gone a
few days almost a week without mom
it's gonna be pretty imperative that she
gets on our formula right away
otherwise she's gonna go south really
fast
come on in and we'll shut it ready to
meet the baby
i bet you want to come out we already
love you
sometimes babies from the wild they're
getting dehydrated and things like that
so we end up having to
feed them i'll give her a couple tries
and if she doesn't take it then i'll
have to call the vet and see what she
wants us to do
like oh yeah first try
okay that's awesome i didn't think she
was gonna take a bottle that fast
little baby girl is going to have a
great life here at the wildlife center
okay take a breather the opportunities
that we can open up with our education
ambassador program
as well as just increasing our herd and
bringing some new genetic diversity
i'm really excited to see where this
could go that's a lot baby girl
i've got high hopes for her she's like
but i want more
a lot of people come here and they don't
know very much about the ocean they know
you can go and
catch fish there's salmon and the sea
life center's
the only public aquarium here in alaska
so we do a great job of actually
educating people
of all the different ecosystems we have
here in alaska
[Music]
so pat is our giant pacific octopus
she's the largest that we have here at
the aquarium
we got pat about three years ago and
when we did she was the size of a
quarter and we've raised her
ever since so
the octopus encounter is a chance to
come behind the scenes and actually
meet one of our octopus we don't force
them to do anything so if she wants to
interact she'll come over if she doesn't
she's going to do her own thing
looks like she's going to interact you
guys want to reach on in
60 pounds of octopus
all octopus have different personalities
that's definitely
very outgoing she likes to kind of reach
up and touch people and she's a great
animal though to be interacting with
she likes you she's a little bit slimy
they're just very curious and they're
they're invertebrate but they're
incredibly intelligent is that your
thumb yet
it's really impressive how strong each
one of their sucker discs are
these big sucker discs here could
probably hold about 15 pounds
individually
this is a special octopus encounter
today because it's the
last encounter pat will be used on
before she's released in the wild
pat's reaching a milestone in her life
and that's the age of sexual maturity
we've noticed signs of her being really
active in the tank and
pretty mischievous and furious
which is usually indicative of them
being ready to find a mate
so she broke one of the
pump inflows in her tank
she actually cracked it so because of
that we had to take her out of there and
drain it and fix it so this is uh
this is what she broke off she
completely
ripped it this is the time when they
always are
causing mischief in their tanks so she's
been a great animal but
it's definitely time to let her go and
give her a shot to reproduce in the wild
[Music]
so i was able to get a hold of this bald
eagle impaled on a branch
75 feet up in the air i know honey
my plan is to just slide the bird off
the branch but i can't
ah victoria has a hold of the bird but
it's
it looks like its wing is stuck through
a branch
and yeah you can hear him screaming he's
probably in a lot of pain
hold on to me please plan b
is i'm going to break the branch
yeah i can't break it i have the eagle
but i can't break it
oh it's so sad
oh he's biting her he just bitter i
think
oh stop it the eagle is biting me
he just wants to bite victoria i'll be
fine
ben bitten i just want to get them down
plan c we finally get an axe brought up
to us
this is insane
that that made me a little bit worried
just because
i knew it was going to be a sudden drop
[Applause]
okay okay so i think they're gonna pull
it back and then lower
oh my god so he's not heavy but he does
have that stick through his wing which
is going to be kind of hard
[Applause]
i have the eagle i've got him sticking
all
now i've got to get him down to the
ground
[Music]
fortunately he's a male bald eagle males
weigh
quite a bit less than females and i
just wonder if this had been a female
would i have been able to carry this
bird all the way down to the ground
i'm gonna let go here i'm sorry
you're poor baby oh isn't this romantic
can you get it jen oh buddy
how in the heck victoria someone else
mike
get over here mike the first thing we
need to do
is get rid of this branch we can't even
transport the bird
back to the raptor center with this huge
branch sticking out
i know bud i'm happy we got this far but
with that branch through his wing
there's a good chance
that it's going to be a euthanasia case
did he bite you in the face
oh tons i know i know
you're mad you are feisty
you can bite me you can bite me bite me
friend of mine is able to cut through
the branch and make it smaller
and that's when we really start to
realize what's going on here
that bird had twisted itself around
sorry i'm so sorry oh god his wing is
torn up
on three one two three oh man this
eagle is so feisty i'll do what i can to
save it thank you so
much that was really scary
i didn't think about how scary it would
be
when i said i wanted to go up because i
was only thinking about the eagle and
we got it let's go take care of this
bird
my theory is that this bird had a piece
of food most likely a piece of salmon
and was being chased by another bird
eagles are funny there can be food lying
everywhere
and i have seen eagles fight over one
piece of food
and i've seen them hit power lines and
run into windows
because they're not paying close
attention
i'm pretty confident that's what was
going on it was about food
[Music]
okay what have you got here you've
already bitten me 20 times
if the damage is too much we will have
to end his suffering now
like hi look at you
you go ready to kill us first thing he
needs is a hood
once they can't see they calm down and
when they're calm they're much less
likely to bite us
i told you oh you booger
[Music]
how bad does it look
well the potato tendon is intact it was
lower
oh good this is great news the potato
tendon is so
important if this is a bird's wing
it runs from here to here and creates
this giant triangle of skin
which allows the bird to get lift when
it's flying
if that tendon was destroyed then it
would be
over right now oh i hate to put this
bird through it but i think i may at
least do a quick
sutures honestly when i was rescuing
this bird i was thinking oh we're just
keeping it from a very long slow painful
death
but now that i've seen what's actually
going on
i have a little bit of hope for this
bird
all the tissue looks really healthy you
know obviously there's a hole through
the skin
but i'm not seeing torn up muscles or
ruptured tendons i'm nervous
that this bird isn't going to be able to
hold its wing up
but it's absolutely worth giving this
bird a chance
it's kind of an emotional roller coaster
you know you see it you think it's dead
yeah it's alive
yay it's not just alive it's alive and
wanting to kill me
oh my god this is great
oh nuts what found another hole
and then i see the second hole and is it
big
yeah it's huge
[Music]
i'm i'm kind of disappointed right now
after 26 years you'd think i'd not be
disappointed but
i still am i'm
nervous about that large hole i
i don't think this hole will heal
well enough for him to be able to fly
again but
you never know maybe he'll surprise us
[Music]
what cracks me up about muskox is they
start off so
cute the cutest baby mammals that i've
ever cared for
and then they grow up and they look like
angry old men
muskox were once nearly extinct from
alaska so they they're a really great
success story they've really bounced
back and are doing well in the state
the ox gear they're ambassadors for
their species we do a lot of talks and
education
kind of spreading the word about muskox
in alaska
[Music]
we're really careful and cautious with
our animals that we have
already on site so quarantine's a
requirement for any animal that comes
into human care
we picked up this new baby muskox the
staff decided we're going to call her
athena
she kind of has a sad story uh mom was
eaten by a grizzly
we're gonna make sure we're following
quarantine protocol we're gonna wear
special clothing make sure everybody's
healthy
because she came in from the wild we
don't want her to potentially bring
stuff and spread it to the rest of our
herds
so the pants are just something cheap
that i don't mind getting ruined and
they're easy to throw over my work pants
hi honey hi kiddo uh this is our first
chance to do with iana's preliminary
medical check
so cute let's save that
figure okay all right
i got to get a good view so you got to
pick her up
[Music]
there's still umbilicus on there
uh so she's still got her umbilical
cords that makes me think she's only a
weak
she's so little and clearly we are
best friends at this point you might
only be just a week old she's at a
critical point right now just because
she has been without her mom for a
couple days
we're gonna fill in for mom and it's
just a matter of her uh
realizing that
[Music]
she gets six feedings a day every four
hours so we're up at midnight and four
am making sure this little girl gets
uh what she needs
to eventually she'll be weaned off her
bottle after about six months
done good job kid i'm in love with her
me too
she is just super spunky
because she is so young we're hoping for
her to be an education animal where we
can do things like take her on walk she
can tell
educate people a little bit more about
muscles out in the wild
what's your manner did you see that
are you okay is your leg hurt i noticed
while i was in there that baby athena
seems to have a little bit of a limp
going on
i bet i don't know just kind of got a
hobble
so i don't know if she's got injured
somehow while she was out there running
away from the grizzly bear
or what really is going on with that so
we'll just have to keep an eye on it
yeah she's definitely tender what do you
think
we're gonna give her the best care we
can and hope she does well
[Music]
[Music]
loading up the truck we're uh getting
ready to release pat
beautiful day for it pat is our current
giant pacific octopus we have here at
the sea life center this is the largest
species of octopus in the world
and they're extremely plentiful here off
the coast of alaska
she was just removed about a week ago so
this may be a little more familiar than
normal
octopus they'll actually die after they
reproduce
so they'll usually lay their eggs and
they'll guard those eggs for
up to a year and then after those eggs
hatch the female will usually crawl away
a few meters and die i've gotten pretty
attached to pat within the last three
years
but this is our one shot to reproduce in
the wild
hopefully she can find a mate to
reproduce with so it's kind of the goal
putting her back in the wild
oh yeah this is exciting i mean we all
get to do this every day and
i think pat's excited too to get out
there
she knows something's up she's probably
excited about it
[Music]
so we're taking dad the octopus to start
a new life right near the sea life
center here in resurrection bay
our dive plans to take her down to
around 40 feet
we'll find a nice safe spot in an
environment that looks
like it would be an octopus-friendly
area no predators around
good cave
this is our moment of freedom right now
pat has definitely sparked a lot of
people's interests
to be able to realize that they're not
big and scary and dangerous they're
very curious and there's a lot to be
learned about them still
[Music]
she seemed happy right away we saw a
color change in
pat and that's due to just her
acclimating to a new environment
and trying to blend in
[Music]
she's a little off the dating game but
we'll see how she does
[Music]
feeding time for the herd animals around
here all the ungulates you know they
really rely on their herd
to just be confident they kind of need
that camaraderie
to make sure they don't get a little
crazy town on us
surprisingly enough our muskox herd is
actually gonna grow by two this summer
baby athena got here last week and now
we have baby artemis
artemis was also on the run from a
grizzly bear on the slope
she loves butt scratches though chunk of
monk
but it's kind of nice if we got two of
them this year
and that'll help just their mental
health they can't be together with the
whole herd until their quarantine's over
but today will be a big day for them
it's a big day for my staff too we're
gonna put these two little girls
together
even though there's only two of them at
least they have each other but first we
actually have to clean out the pen
they're going into so we had a couple of
reindeer in there so we need to clean
that out and then this will be their
home for the summer
went to school for eight years so that i
could pick up poop
so this the sooner these baby guys can
get on
normal vegetation look how good that is
grasses and sedges and stuff you know
it's just gonna help their development
in their guts
[Music]
it's time to move them thank you
it's not worth the stress to put them in
a kennel when we can just pick them up
for a second and walk them over
okay look at they're going on an
adventure
it's okay it's almost over i don't know
good job howie you're ready hi lady what
do you think
oh she's got so much grass now
artemis might be a little more of a
handful than athena but i think it'll
all work out just fine
i don't want her to be stressed out any
longer than she needs to be
so the quicker i go the quicker she'll
get to be with her new buddy
austin just ran for it man are you ready
to meet your friend
we've got a little 25-pound athena and
40-pound artemis so
kind of david and goliathy but artemis
kind of has a hard head so i just hope
she's not too rough on miss athena
and they'll figure it out and they'll be
friends instantly that's my hope
[Music]
so artemis is super sketched out she's
the she's the bigger one on the backside
of brittany over there
artie is super like judgy
[Laughter]
[Music]
but we want to make sure she doesn't
beat up on athena and things like that
so
[Music]
they're both following their own
personal moms
artemis spent a little bit more time in
the wild she's a little bit bigger so
she
knows how to be a musk ox a lot more
than athena does
[Music]
there we go oh
athena caught right on and figured out
oh i'm a muskox too you're my friend
[Music]
i think they're going to be forever
friends
so athena's still got a little bit of a
hobble she can kind of see she's
tender on it
[Music]
we think she probably just sprained it
our vet's gonna be here next week so
we'll check out athena's leg
i just really hope our little girl is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
saturdays that's our big day at the
raptor center
where i follow up and all the birds that
have been treated throughout the week
and i am definitely invested in this
bird when you go up at a 75-foot ladder
to get a bird you just can't help it
getting a little attached to it
this bird that was skewered through the
wing
is now called skewer and one more
skewer has a hole in his wing about this
size okay everybody out oh this is gonna
cause drama
i don't want a bird to suffer needlessly
and so
if skewer tells me you know through the
x-rays through looking at its injuries
that it is just not a good bird for
captivity maybe it's going to be
dragging its wing
um unfortunately i will have to
euthanize it
so i lightened it up quite a bit so i
could see the soft tissue
and i'm seeing soft tissue swelling over
here so
you know you think about what this bird
has been through it was probably
flapping and hitting its wings it's very
lucky that it didn't break something
while it was hitting its wings against
the tree
i'm looking at the bones
things look good so
at this point we are very hopeful that
skewer could be placed
in a zoo or an education
program with that hole in the wing i
just don't know if he's going to be able
to fly
dr v thinks already he's not going to be
releasable just because of that
but he is very bitey which is a good
sign
and just seems like he's got a lot of a
lot of them in him
so
oh my god
[Music]
we are shocked at how well skewer is
flying with a hole this big
just a couple weeks ago he was 75 feet
up in a tree
skewer through his right wing we need to
catch him
so dr b can see if he's healing okay
look at how well he's flying i have two
holes in my wing
but look at me i can fly higher than any
of you guys
how in the world is he doing that i'm
just thinking of how hard it's gonna be
to catch him now that he's flying so
good
all right here we go
[Music]
skewer is a fairly small bald eagle but
he has a big personality
every little thing sets him flying
crashing into things
hopefully his personality is not gonna
cause problems for him
uh well i guess we'll just do this
we've still got a lot of swelling here
but flying great huh
oh damn got a little tendon exposure
which i do not like
at all oh no that's not no bueno
he had a nice scab forming and i suspect
when he was flying he cracked the scab
and the scab was covering his tendon
and this tendon is vitally important for
flight
if that tendon dries out we will lose
the ability for that bird to hold its
wing up
and of course to fly so i'm trying to be
pretty aggressive in my treatment i
covered it to
prevent moisture escape and i did a
laser treatment
this is a cold laser and so what it will
do is
increase the blood supply to the area
we've also put the bird in icu to reduce
the chance of it extending its wing
which is going to pull the scab
and cause it to break again and that
would
probably ruin spurts chances of being
able to fly
we have to protect him from himself so
he can heal
here in alaska we are very used to
finding wild animals
sharing space with humans and we respond
to calls
all around from the very northern tip of
alaska to southeast
but today we don't have to go far call
came in
for an animal in our hometown of seward
we've been dealing with an elephant seal
right here in the harbor
this is the fourth time we have had to
move this animal or that has come up on
on in a in a public area first it was in
a
parking lot near the condos in the
harbor
then it was at lowell point now it is
choosing to be on this boat ramp that's
under construction
she's in her annual motorcycle which
looks pretty nasty
but it's a very normal process
she does not seem bothered at all by the
construction activity but
her presence definitely halts a lot of
the work she's looking a lot more alert
today than she has in the past for sure
[Music]
it's better for us and hopefully for her
to get her to a more remote location
[Music]
don't go around the other side of me
norm just the other side of me so she's
not
yep that's how you tip the cage right up
under her
it's probably a lot like somebody
feeling like they have the flu
they just don't feel well they don't
want to eat so she clearly
picked this ramp like our couch when we
have the flu so
[Music]
now we're good clearly as far as we've
gotten
in the past is not working she is uh she
is just has a strong sense of returning
to a comfortable spot
we're hoping we find a spot that she
enjoys just as much as the boat ramp
it takes a little bit of coaxing uh she
looks around kind of assesses the scene
we have to just tilt the cage a little
bit to give a little help from gravity
okay
our best case scenario is that she
decides to stay put out here and doesn't
come back into sewer
hi little lady what are you doing
can i see your eye so one of our
sitka deer has what looks like kind of a
red and
inflamed tear duct so i'm going to get
a pretty good picture of it as close as
i can here
so rude and send it on to our vet
she definitely does have a swollen right
tear duct
area
[Music]
vet thinks it's a bug bite if the
swelling doesn't go down or if it gets
worse then i'll let her know either
tonight or tomorrow if you notice any
change
the first day artie and athena were kind
of skeptical of each other
but um we can come in here now and
normally they lay together behind the
pin
like right next to each other so they
pretty much do everything together now
they're really close
athena but athena's limp is really
concerning to me
so our vet came out here took some
x-rays uh so we can get to the bottom of
what's going on
all right come on wow so i've got these
x-rays for athena
if you had a chance and can come over to
the infirmary so we can go over them
real quick
unfortunately we don't have very good
news to report about athena
that's not good news see where the
bone's eaten away
you can see the growth plate is
completely deteriorating which is
a pretty indicative of a septic bone
infection
as far as treatment goes there is no
options other than amputating the leg
and having a 600-pound animal walking
around on three legs just isn't an
option
it's got to be super painful it's not
fair to make her suffer
once we saw the x-rays we knew it was
kind of doomsday
that's bad news yeah in the best
interest of athena and her quality of
life it's gonna be best to put an end to
her suffering
[Music]
come on athena it's okay
[Music]
come here since athena was so small
we just did it right there by the
infirmary
artemis we took into the back of the
pasture so she didn't have to be around
we didn't have to see any of the stuff
that was going on because she's already
super protective of athena
you're always going to get attached to
the animals you can't properly care for
animals if you don't
give your whole self to them and love
them in every unconditional way so
it's always going to chip away at you
when you lose one it's
it hurts the whole team
we try not to get attached right at the
beginning because that's kind of when
they're the most vulnerable
um i fail every single time
[Music]
artemis knew within 10 minutes something
was off
and she's constantly looking for her
[Music]
it's really hard now seeing artemis
kind of by herself when she had athena
we had one awful outcome with one muskox
but
[Music]
[Applause]
hopefully with artemis we're gonna get
that amazing outcome where you see her
out with everybody having a great old
time and gets to live a really nice long
[Music]
life
every time a bird comes through our
doors
our goal is to return them back into the
wild
but sometimes birds are deemed
non-releasable
due to sustaining some sort of permanent
injury or impairment
that prevent them from being able to
actively
hunt on their own in the wild
and then that's when they'll become an
educational ambassador
to teach people about their species
instead
[Music]
so we've been watching skewers wounds
heal over time and every week
we look it doesn't look like he's
healing that much
and then this week when we had a look
it was like a miracle but boy that looks
a lot better right there all along here
used to have scab we went from a giant
scab
to a very tiny scab it was amazing how
much healing
happened underneath a big change it was
huge progress and that's what made me
decide to move him out into main flight
our main flight is the final stage of
rehab for our birds
just the ultimate place for the eagles
to complete their rehabilitation
[Music]
caring for injured bald eagles means a
lot to me
but if we can teach people that these
birds are amazing and if you think
they're amazing you've got to save their
habitat
then we're actually doing something
and that's the bigger message that's
really important to me
okay one two three
i would say he's defying the odds right
now because we've
never had a situation like this where we
had a bird with a huge hole in its wing
pretty amazing that the bird can even
fly
there he goes
even with a big hole in his wing he's an
amazing flyer
i want him strengthening his muscles
i want him stretching his wings to make
sure that he isn't forming any
adhesions or scar tissue that would keep
him from opening his wings
and if he continues to heal beautifully
we might even be able to release him
uh we're about to do artie's weekly
weigh-in
come here kid she's doing really great
she's my little rock star
and she's gonna be a really good
education animal
so even though athena is gone uh we
still have artemis you know she still
needs all that love and care and
attention
um so we still have to bottle raise her
we still have to make sure she's all the
healthy
and she progresses and meets her weight
goals
her stance is now wide enough to where
she can not be on the scale if she wants
to
cheater no you were so close artemis
uh is definitely a spitfire you know
she's definitely been a headstrong
muskox
but she looks really good she's gaining
weight and she looks happy and we're
excited to work with her for the summer
89 already has about six more months in
quarantine before
putting her in with a herd until then we
just need to spend as much time as we
possibly can with her being someone for
her to hang out with
okay uh sheila we're heading in right
now
today's a big day hopefully we are going
to be releasing skewer
first we need to catch him in main
flight and skewer
and see if that hole in his wing has
healed enough for release
main flight is a big l-shaped space with
a high area called the balcony
we need him to fly into the balcony so
that we can let the curtain down
and then catch him in a smaller area
they're wary of us as they should be so
we have to kind of
hide
i can't really hide myself where the
switch is at to close the curtain
so i thought well maybe i'll just bring
a sheet in that kind of matches the
color of the wall and
hide in it it's kind of a pain but it
works pretty well i think
so the birds are flying in but then
flying out really fast
they're not staying in wait here comes
somebody
like so no skewer skewer skewer
dang it
takes a lot of patience to wait much
like fishing
they're coming they're coming
okay okay we have skewer
[Music]
that skewer right there you get a nice
butt shot
i am anxious to see what the size of the
hole will be
and also if that tendon has
really fully healed all right
drum roll i'm a little nervous because
if it hasn't healed
then he shouldn't be released this bird
is
kind of a spaz and that puts it more
at risk for keeping it in human care
uh you want to open it yeah okay of
course i do
let's go oh nice blood feathers coming
in
holy crap look at how tiny it is wow
are you kidding me and look at
how beautifully that is tendon is
covered
look it looks this big yeah sweet
it looks amazing it's he's got
feathers growing back and um the hole is
a lot smaller than it was when we put
them in there
it's pretty amazing so
i think we're gonna go ahead and release
it wasn't
until i actually looked at that wing
that i could say
we're doing this we're doing the release
it was pretty exciting carrying skewer
up to that final step that
release pad that we have
skewer is my miracle eagle
such an epic rescue
[Music]
i just kept thinking about how skewers
started
in a tree hanging upside down
and i thought he was dead
and then the roller coaster of what he's
gonna do
[Music]
and then we're finally able to release
him
[Music]
the odds were very stacked against
skewer when we first got him
he's just got a fight to him he's he's a
bird that you know has this
he's gonna make it
this is one bird i will never ever
forget
there's just always more birds that need
help so
skewer's gone but more birds will come
along there will always be more
[Music]
you